this episode is brought to you by gray
block pizza gray block 18:11 Pico
Boulevard in Los Angeles on the way to
the beach you know where it is stop in
get that hitter this episode is brought
to you by star Flo comm star Flo the
location for fans trying to link up and
get closer to their favorite celebrities
think about a celebrity
anybody could be Andre Agassi could be
Alfonzo Riviera anyone star Flo is a
safer ecosystem where your information
will not be sold on the black market or
markets available to any ethnicity it
provides a hub for consumers to access
their favorite talents and celebrities
and exclusive content in seconds think
about seconds there's a couple of them
right there you could be on Star Flow
access and celebs it's available in the
App Store or its star flow com star flow
stays out of the sell your information
secondary market that's a dirty
territory it's a safe place where
algorithms and sneaky pixels that
secretly use your own searches and
information to sell you stuff aren't
allowed it's built for fans as an
aggregator for Twitter Facebook and
YouTube so they can get to one place and
use the in-app purchase of tokens to get
exclusive content and experiences the
big fish are trying to eat all the
minnows out there soon they're going to
keep certain types of entertainment off
of certain web sites but not star flow
star flow is that gangsta gang of menos
that are creating a wave so let the
grunion run down your tongue and get
that hitter check out star flow comm and
see what safe consumerism of your
favorite celebrity content looks like
and today's my birthday man
so I'm excited to be here and I'm
excited to spend it with you guys and I
got this beautiful hit that came in from
my boy tiny sand whoo let's go
[Music]
[Applause]
it's tiny out there lickin man he making
them strength dirty man
[Music]
that's a boneyard cover by mr. tiny sand
who and some people if you are new to
this past weekend you you don't know
that tiny sand who is a he's just a
figure he hit me up on the email and he
send in these wild riffs and that's one
of his dirty pieces right there that's
tiny sand who busting something naughty
for everybody everybody that's a decent
person and you know what man
that's not enough for me man today my
birthday I want this man I want to catch
this hit two let's go there you go huh
sending them choppers boy cuz we got
people in the water
[Music]
hug your hamster tight hug your cousin
boy if they cute [ __ ] touch they ass
a little this is America
[Music]
[Applause]
what's up you little Christmas tampons
how you guys livin huh you've been
drinking your own bathwater huh
you've been saving food in your teeth
overnight and eating it in the morning
you ever do that have that little rise
and shine snack hiding behind one of
your molars you bust that little hoe out
throw it down your gullet Savage that's
a savage way to start your day I'm I'm
I'm happy to be here with today with you
guys I'm grateful to be here today with
you guys today is my birthday you know
and and I am 38 years old I'm 38 I'm
coming in 38 hot years you know I want
to thank my mother I'm gonna thank you
know my father a 70 year old man think
about that a 70 year old man busted a
strong one boy you know my father was
born in in 1910 my grandfather was born
in 1880 you know I'm coming I'm coming
out of those wagon wheel genetics you
know I'm coming back from the you know
the days when children used to play with
wooden dolls you know and if they put a
um and sometime if they if a tooth fell
out of their mouth and they put it under
their pillow somebody else in the family
would steal it and try to install it
into their mouth you know I come from
them type of times and uh and you know
that's just someone what's in my DNA
some history and I am just grateful man
I'm grateful that that bust happened you
know because I'm a product of a nut
that's all we are I mean we're a product
of this of a sensation isn't that
interesting that think sometimes what
you know sometimes I forget that
sometimes I forget that I'm the part
that I am a sensation happened of just
uh yeah and that's how and then I began
and we all began off of a sensation you
know and that's one of the things that
I'm learning more and more that keeps me
alive is is is finding feelings that are
good because a lot of my life I spent
just swimming in these circles of dirty
water
you know of ill feelings and just you
know it's like when you it's like when
you just speak in a bathwater it's like
when you stay in your own bathwater too
long you know sometime if you lay in the
tub and you soak it feels good but after
about 45 minutes dude you don't even
realize you might have you know busted a
quart of urine in there who knows your
hair is just all just oil on the top and
you're still sitting in there and that's
where I spend a lot of my life just
wasting my time you know but now I'm
looking to live on the same level of
where I was created searching for
sensation I want to feel something you
know I want to feel something and a long
time in my life I did not want to do
that but today man I'm here to feel I'm
gonna take another little stab at this
is that bone yard my tiny almost switch
it on
this one just gets me today
that's that hitter I don't know who made
that for me I can't remember off the go
back in check and I'm sorry to not cite
them I think it could have been a Brad
Levine it could have been Jessi Lucero
I'm not sure but it's a sweet beat and I
appreciate it and I consider that a gift
for my birthday and thank you very much
happy birthday to you if it's your
birthday out there you know or happy day
to you whatever it is today is the day
that we have you know today is the day
that we have we're going to make the
most out of it you know all these Irish
I'm sure a lot of Irish people are
recovering you guys had that um that st.
Patrick's Day and I spent I just got
back from Tacoma and Spokane up there in
Washington in that Pacific Northwest and
I you know I really liked those areas
especially um I mean Tacoma I've been to
before people came out we sold out the
show's mana you know dislike the first
time you know in my career that I feel
like I've had you know and I don't want
to say fans but I feel like I've just
had you know a lot of love coming out
you know nope
no [ __ ] in the audience know people
you know ruining the show or being too
selfish or you know we're just there and
we're having a good time and a man I
just felt so accepted and I want to
thank everybody over there in Tacoma
you know Tacoma it's out there on the it
said it's that uh you know it's that
sixth finger of Seattle and to try you
know try it just Seattle tries to hide
it off in the suburbs I get like it's
not a real place but tacoma's out there
you know Tacoma you can go over there
and they got they they call it the
Tacoma aroma in the air because somebody
they said in the distance they're having
like a there built you know making
stacks of paper they got a paper mill or
people are burn and [ __ ] or whatever I
don't know but they got that scent in
the air but I like that come over here
to Tacoma get a hit get a whiff off of
that off of that universe people over
there and see
yo y'all pet and salmon and doing all of
this [ __ ] you know and hide and grin you
know hiding granola and putting you know
you know wale tears suppositories and
the babies asses and doing all this
futuristic you know lifestyle stuff you
know wrapping your cousin in kale and
hiding them in a [ __ ] sand pit or
something for a couple hours so that
their skin will look nice you go to
Tacoma boy anything anything will happen
I was leaving the the comedy club there
was some drunk lady she ran into a truck
right walking then she [ __ ] started
fist fighting she started fist fighting
a dang Dodge Ram so that's what's going
on real [ __ ] over there in Tacoma and I
got out there to Spokane and Spokane
it's almost like it's like the Midwest
in the northwest if you've been a Peoria
Illinois or someone like that you would
you know um you know where a place where
you just feel a little bit of Americana
it's right there in Spokane and I had a
great time and I want to thank those
people for coming out thank you so much
and it was st. Patty's Day over there
Spokane I must say this you know st.
Patty's Day if you want to it's like the
one day a year as a man if you aren't
gay that you could be gay I've never
seen so many dudes and I think I talked
about this last st. Patrick's Day
kissing each other just because they got
a green shirt on
it's like oh hey you know like men just
drinking all that day drink and make you
kiss another man and then everybody's
saying no but everybody's thinking well
maybe and especially st. Patrick's Day
everybody got a shirt kiss me I'm Irish
and I saw I saw at least 20 men you know
10 pairs of two men you know forty lips
just hit each other head on beside that
head on collision of lips and they were
just all in the name of Ireland I guess
and alcoholism
what people wearing kilts men wearing
skirts showing up wearing beads and
skirts kissing other men because
everybody's Irish all of a sudden you
know and so that's the Gateway I mean
that's if you want to be gay you know
how Irish do you want to get you want to
duck off over here behind this Subaru
and [ __ ] touch each other's warm
kneecaps how Irish you want to get
because I saw some adult men with
families getting real Irish you know I'm
talking I'm talking about behind the
shown he's kind of Irish because when I
was young they would have a lot of
straight men would meet up behind the
Shoney's and you know jerk each other
off and do stuff like that and then go
back to their families because when I
was young you couldn't just you know it
wasn't as people who were gay couldn't
openly be gay and you know I think about
that struggle sometimes with that could
you imagine being something and not
being able to be it yes I mean it's just
I couldn't imagine what that you know
that pain of that but then there was
probably for a lot of gay men there was
that one day oh here it comes put it on
the calendar
March 17th when all I got to do is put
on a green shirt and I can get a [ __ ]
out without any judgment never then look
man I saw it in to call me you think
they are in Spokane you think these men
out there they hard heads and they
living like this and that they got three
and four children but they see they
suddenly they see another man who's
looking hell Irish and all of a sudden I
saw these two men just kiss face-to-face
and they could have been family that's
another thing you got a hot cousin
you think your stepdaddy's cute it's
March 17th [ __ ] slide I'm a note
check yes or no Papa you know this is
that's the day it should just be the day
where you anything goes that's what they
should start calling it you know let's
get Irish you know I'm saying if you a
lady and you want to you know you want
to touch somebody up in the vulva do
your thing do that digit dance you know
get your carpals out get your carpals
out and go through that brief filing
cabinet
do a little bit of a gelling you know
what I'm saying boy they only got two
folders and that cabinet boo-boo but
people are getting hella Irish man and
you know and it's a joyous day and
that's one thing you know I don't drink
right now in my life and that's one
thing I miss is uh I do miss some day
drinking because anything could happen
in your day drinking somebody jerk you
off in a truck you jerk yourself off
somewhere it's daytime you know it's
like the wolves are out it's like full
it's almost like a full moon but all day
long and that's what I'm always saying
Patty's was for me that's what st.
Patty's was for me man it was fun eating
chowder and drinking beer and people
puking adults crying man I saw I saw
this one lady she was probably 37 just
you know when you're crying so much and
she was trying to eat some what did she
have a bag of um what are those chips
those um they are like these little hats
these chips they look like a little
bitty hats like you could put them on
your finger and make five little hats or
if they had a gnome and he was wearing
like a little corn hat you know or a
dunce you know like if someone if they
if these have these dunce hats they were
real tall v-neck looking hats
upside-down these you know hats and if
you were like a dunce they would make
you wear this dunce hat but these little
what are they bugles bugles chips and
you this lady had a sack of bugles and I
don't know if you ever had these bugles
chips but they they're they absorb all
the moisture in your mouth so they dry
you out and this lady boy she was on she
was on some I mean she was making salt
water she was making salt water up there
she was just salinated out of her face
just just wasted and crying and that's
something I love to see on st. Pat I
don't want to you know I don't want that
lady to have this pain or whatever she's
going through but it's alcohol-induced
you know she had on that big pink
lipstick and all these different
necklaces you know kiss me I'm Irish
[ __ ] me I'm Irish you know
help me raise my kids I'm Irish she was
getting out there extensively with some
of her ideas you know based on the on
the country on this one this little
island of Britain or Ireland I don't
know if it's an island I don't know
Ireland Island I could easily see
somebody get confused and think they
live in Jamaica but everybody's white
you know but um but yeah this lady was
bursting she was just just cried as
drunk crying and trying to eat these
bugles at the same time I mean it won't
pop at one point I swear she was kind of
dipping the bugles in her tears so she
would have enough moisture to get them
bugles down her you know down her gullet
to gullet them bugles and that was you
know that Spokane baby people set it off
and people came out we had a great time
and we had a great time over there in
Spokane but yeah if you I think I you
know we should just say st. Patty's Day
is the one day where if you trying to
bust a nut on somebody that's got the
same genitalia as you then you go on
because to me it gets more and more it's
not really green it's more a little more
it's got a little more rainbow in it and
you'd see a lot of gay men I remember
last year in New Orleans I was doing st.
Patrick's Day down there with two of my
good buddies and you would see a lot of
me a lot of gay men out there you know
trying to dress real straight you know
wearing like um you know beavis and
butthead t-shirts or you know wearing um
you know wearing uh you know not
turtlenecks you know not looking real
gay or wearing like kind of gay attire
and I know that you know that's kind of
a generalization I'm not trying to say
gay people look one way or whatever but
you know what the [ __ ] I'm talking about
you know if you had if you had if you
put a tracker on all the turtlenecks in
America most of them would end up on
probably most of those trackers would
lead you to the homes of gay men or
Italians probably you know or male
librarians so I'm just I'm playing the
odds here but they had a lot of
you know you'd see a lot of these men
trying to look real straight you know
wearing like NASCAR t-shirts and [ __ ]
but also with the Irish beads I'm Irish
just trying to frickin lock just trying
to lock lips with some straight men who
are out there letting their feelings
loose you know and that's how it happens
next thing you know boy next thing you
know your leg hair is all tangled up
with another man's leg hair and that's
the bit you know like you know I've
never felt an attraction to men you know
essentially you know I have felt an
attraction to men in the sense that I
wanted more of a brotherhood in my life
and I wanted to have more male friends
but I never felt that sensual attraction
and I think it's just like because when
I think about laying in bed with another
man the sex part I mean you know I'm
saying you could wear a blindfold or you
know put on like some rodeo music I mean
you could do some things maybe to get
through some of the sexual miss
but then the lay there and feel your leg
hair tangle up with another man's leg
hair dude that's when I'm out that ain't
them you know that's when I know that
for me at this point in my life that's
not the road I'm looking to get down you
know cuz what if you have real strong
leg hair and your legs get locked up
next to each other in your hair just leg
hairs all tangled up you know SS that's
something out there and that's real
Irish that's soo bad that is that's
Irish you know that is Irish but I'm
happy to be here with you guys man we
had some nice people that came out in
both of those cities this was a call
that came from Tacoma I'm just gonna
play it I'm gonna keep going with things
that are going on in my head I just want
you I just want to I want to include
other people in this pod today here we
go hey what's up there Jacob from
Washington my girlfriend we came out in
Tacoma on Friday at 8:00 nice once a
time dude thanks for coming out Jacob
and thanks for bringing your lady you
know I did see a lot of couples that
came out and a lot of couples that
listen to the podcast together and
that's pretty cool you know like I mean
I don't know I think that's a special
thing you know there's something special
when you have somebody that you care
about in you and you just do things
together whether it's a podcast or you
know whether you you know split them you
got a little bit of milk left and a jug
and you maybe you pour a little bit more
and your girls bow and you you know when
you cut yours with water you know so you
got that lean milk in yours but and it
doesn't even look like milk it looks a
little squirrelly you know it looks like
uh something they mighta came out of a
[ __ ] week ferret or something but you
know and you sit there and you eat
cereal together you consume a podcast
together there's something special and I
saw a lot of couples I see a lot of
couples and I'm grateful for that I
appreciate it
let's hear more Jacob you look so
[ __ ] fine put you up home just
stomach hurt
thanks man I appreciate him out we had
some good times dude it was fun it was a
lot of fun you know if you noticed there
was a pregnant lady there and he made a
joke about um kind of waiting for hot
dogs and start serving it but doesn't do
she was laughing so hard I thought she
was about to give birth right there man
I thought you're dissing premature
childbirth and that was wild Wow so they
had a pregnant lady out there he said
and thanks man I didn't see her you know
usually I spot him boy you know I'm
saying I used to do a little whale
watching that's what I call it and and
usually if you see a pregnant lady out
there you know what I'm not saying
pregnant woman's as whales you know I
ain't saying but I'm saying that they
caught that Moby Dick at one part and
now they just Staton and now they hide
in little humans now they playing that
hide and ghosts that hide-and-go-seek
game but they gotta count for nine
months before they find that little
[ __ ] between their legs and I
didn't see that but that would be
amazing you know if somebody you know
you hit him with that right joking and
they squirrel out you know they squirrel
out and next thing you know they gotta
buy another ticket because I got one
more person sitting at their table I did
spit you know I mean this is already Tim
dude a lot of these episodes get a
little bit gay bro but you know what
that's life sometime life gets gay
sometime life gets gay
you know I got hit by two gay men one
time and they were hit they hit me in a
car and you want to talk about things
just being straight suddenly I'm in my
world chillin riding you know maybe
listen to some Alice in Chains or some
TLC or something when everybody was
alive and then suddenly bang bang and
now these two dudes were outside of the
car man and they bro if I had a dollar
for every time these two gentlemen
touched me on the shoulder to ask me if
I was okay I have about probably 16
dollars but what I was getting at was
one time I told a joke and some guy you
know bless his heart he laughed so hard
he just came out of the closet in front
of his buddies he was just like and his
boys are like what the [ __ ] Anthony dude
have another drink you know this ain't
this ain't st. Patrick's Day but thank
you for calling jacob from tacoma we
have one more call to come from spokane
from from somebody in the audience and
these are nice men I appreciate this I
don't you know these were just people
that hit up the hotline here we go hey
Theo this is Natasha from Spokane I
brought a bunch of friends out to the
show tonight for a lot of it was the
first exposure to your comedy and we all
had an absolute blast so thank you for
coming out I can't imagine that a rainy
st. Patrick's Day is the best first
impression of the city but hope you felt
welcome and soon thanks Natasha that was
really sweet of you you know and I'm
keeping things sweet on my birthday I'm
keeping things sweet you know I got a
yah you know I know last episode I got a
little bit down in the dumps about you
know some of my career and stuff like
that and where things are and what's
going on in this industry and you know I
just saw I kind of was just you know
it's kind of just it was just self-pity
really you know it's just self-pity
because all I can do really is you know
and I got an email from a burlesque I
got a friend it does burlesque down
there New Orleans and you can follow him
I think on Instagram it's called bust
out burlesque and they um and you know
and she hit me up and she said look you
know
things are going on that's what's going
on but you just got to do your [ __ ] you
know you got to do your [ __ ] and I
appreciated that I needed to hear that I
needed to hear that you know I needed to
hear that if I don't stay positive
they're my work then my environment
isn't positive you know I can't keep
things classy around me if I'm not
trying to show up classy and I know I'm
gonna have my moments you know when we
all are we're gonna have our moments
where you know we we can't do it every
day but if spit 5 out of 7 days I can do
it then I win that week and I
appreciated that message but Natasha
back to your call I had a great time you
know I have a great time in places where
cuz it felt you know Spokane feels like
a real place you know right when I get
there went for a walk just a you know
catch survive see what was going on you
know I went over to a park and they had
a she the biggest red wagon this Radio
Flyer wagon was up somebody put it up
there and they put it in in a park and
it's huge it was one of the neatest
things I've ever seen for children and
they you know and the kids can climb up
the back and I'm talking this thing is
20 feet off the ground maybe 18 feet off
the ground it's 20 feet mate it was big
this thing is huge I put it on my
Instagram it's huge it was it was this
it was the most unique thing I'd ever
seen in a part for children and then the
handle of this big Radio Flyer wagon the
handle of it is the slide so kids are
just sliding down that thing and I
notice right when I got there a couple
kids this one kid he probably was I mean
this kid couldn't have been but about 17
months old he [ __ ] hit that slide
himself and he fit just busted right off
in I mean he skipped off the door off
the end of it just skipped across the
dirt like a rock and it was probably
about six seconds for us how a family
member came and picked him up and you
know what I thought to myself I [ __ ]
love this town cuz that's where I'm from
I'm not from where somebody you know you
sitting there and they got nine family
members everybody wearing Patagonia and
everybody wearing you know specialty
perfumes and colognes
and your daddy smells like France every
day and everybody's catching you at the
bottom of the slide
I'm thinking I'm from that paper you get
to the bottom of the slide that's when
you find out who's at the bottom of the
slide that's when you find out what your
local earth
tastes like when you get a hit of that
nature boy and this 17 month old man
this little dude he look [ __ ] German
bro he had good posture but he popped
off that thing and skipped off the
ground about six times just like I just
like uh I mean just just like uh just
like our little rock you know just like
a little white you know Eastern you're
just like a little white European rock
he just skipped across that dirt and I
said I love this place there was people
out there smoking cigarettes with no
children obviously probably pedophiles
people filing out there looking around
one because once you got up into the
wagon it's a hue it was a huge wagon up
top so it was like 50 60 feet by like 20
feet where there's just you look like
it's about 60 kids up there and at some
adults and they had this one man no
children you know I'm saying not a cool
look you know I'm saying if you want to
get lonely get lonely around adults
that's one of my rules and that's one of
the rules here on this past weekend we
don't get lonely around children because
it's not fair to them and because we
that's when [ __ ] things happen you know
so I don't mean to say that kind of
stuff but that's what's going on what
else man what else happened this weekend
you know I went out there I had a good
time it's my birthday you know last week
I was stuck this week I was talking on
stage actually about uh you know my
father I talked about it last week the
first funeral ever went to and it was
you know it was uh it was really really
sad you know and and then the more I got
to thinking about it I I remember when I
was really young I'd gone to another a
service in our town and I guess you
don't know if at the time I realized it
was a funeral I was too young to know
what was going on and I was probably
seven or something and my father
my mother was out of town you know my
mother would do would you know travel
and do deliveries and stuff regionally
so you know she would have to get out
and do you know delivery she worked for
you know she delivered newspapers and
magazines she delivered uh you know
things to gas stations anything that was
sell at a gas station you know anything
from a light non-food items so anything
from a lighter to you know sometimes
they would have like birthday cards and
stuff and their little you know those
little fart maker things any type of
weird ship my mother was running it
around you know and uh you know and uh
sorry I just yeah it's just you know
that's wild you know to think man
getting caught up here my uh
you know it's wild to think that my mom
would do that you know to take care of
us you know as she's driving all around
um
you notice all around everywhere just
delivering [ __ ] you know to uh to
provide for her kids you know sorry I
think it's just because you know it's my
birthday
I don't mean to keep saying that but I
think it's just got me you know thinking
about what I'm doing here on earth and
you know that I wouldn't be here without
them off without my parents you know you
don't get here that's how you get here
and it just hit me right there thinking
that my mother you know having to leave
her kids to just drive around a bunch of
inanimate objects to make money so you
know even though we've had some tough
times in my life I'm grateful for that
what was I talking about we were talking
about oh so my mother would be out of
town and that means my father would have
to take care of us and my mom didn't she
wouldn't let uh we weren't getting a
sitter when my dad was alive we didn't
get a sitter because my mom felt [ __ ] I
don't care if you 77 years old you got
to take care of these [ __ ] children
he's your children you know and she
would put it on him
so I remember something happened at
school
a young kid a young kid passed away or
maybe his brother something happened and
we and our class went to this went to a
service of funeral service and my dad
had to get me a suit he had to get me a
suit it was his responsibility Vasu you
know I didn't have a suit and so my dad
I mean this is the same dad I mean I
remember for Halloween when you here
supposed to get my brother and I
costumes and he got us both Raggedy Ann
and both of us so he just couldn't see
that well you know he couldn't turn his
neck I mean this man was 77 and this was
77 25 years that you know 31 years ago
this wasn't 77 now 77 now you got these
dudes you know you know you got these
dudes shooting jumpers and you know
working on power lines and you know you
got 77 year olds that are you know
they're doing you know doing stunts and
doing backflips in the park and you know
raping people you got crazy 77 year-olds
out there you know [ __ ] buying swords
and [ __ ] you got real 77 year-olds out
there now but when out but then 77 it
was you know was a little bit more like
about 83 and and even though my father
you know busted nuts obviously they're
pretty late cuz that's how I got here
and I don't mean to be too graphic but
that's how I got here you know to think
that he you know it's the 77 he was
super cop you know super crafty he
wasn't anyway so he got uh he got me a
suit right but the suit was he it was a
it was a costume he I guess he got it
from like Spencer's gifts and this was a
store back in the day where they just
sold you know kind of cool fun stuff for
kids and adults like weird [ __ ] you know
some like sexual and some like just like
crystal balls and like you know those
magic 8-balls and all kinds of [ __ ]
you you know uh fart rocks and danger
taffy and just [ __ ] like that like you
would chew it and it would turn you
whole mouth blue or some or you know
give you a cousin AIDS or some kind of
[ __ ]
but uh but they had this he got this
suit and I guess it was in the window or
something and it was a Beetlejuice
costume remember that movie so I didn't
know any better you know my dad said we
got the suit you go unto the thing so I
am at the service in a Beetlejuice
costume you know and everybody else is
in regular little kids suit or a nice
pant and shirt and I got [ __ ] cobwebs
on my [ __ ] you know and it wasn't even
like a real suit it was like a costume
it was just like a costume and I just
remember feeling like I didn't know what
the [ __ ] was going on in the world you
know everybody else out there you know
they're mourning this you know this
local boy that had gone on and Here I am
out here [ __ ] repping beetlejuice and
looking like a damn I don't know I don't
know but so that was just you know
that's what it was like but that's who
brought me into the world you know a
woman who was traveling around and and
uh and dropping newspapers off to gas
stations and and a man who brought me a
Beetlejuice outfit so I could look
professional at a funeral and knowing my
daddy thought it was a suit he probably
you know he's cheap he probably thought
oh here I got us you know a $14 suit
let's put the boy in it but that's life
man that's life I'm trying to think of a
fun birthday that I had I'm trying to
think of a real fun one that I had
oh I remember this one so a few years
ago I this about 10 years ago nine years
ago I don't know I met up with this
older lady and this older lady was uh
she had one of them you know they
basically these magical crotches at all
I mean she could um you ever seen like a
clown costume where they squirts you
with that water thing where like you
know you you touch their pocket and they
it's a flower that suits you
had that flower that shoots you if you
know what I'm saying I mean she could
[ __ ] water a cactus from about
probably eight and a half feet away you
know I mean she just had accuracy - I
mean just probably like damn I mean I'm
talking like Jesse James with a mouth
full of chewing tobacco she could
[ __ ] you know hit a spittoon probably
at at least seven and three-quarter
feets but so I met this lady and I
didn't know any of this about her I
didn't know any of any of this about her
and um and she worked in she was she
worked in casting she was like a casting
director or something so I meet up with
there were I invited her to a comedy
show in Los Angeles and she shows up and
oh I remember Jennifer Garner was in was
at the at the bar downstairs and I
remember thinking man Jennifer Garner is
fine as hell you know and I I've always
thought I mean Julia Roberts was always
like the one I liked the most Geena
Davis you know who else Oh Jennifer
Garner who I first said well forget it
and then so we got the uh so anyway this
lady shows up and she's she's attractive
I didn't really realize how attractive
she was you know when I cuz I just met
her briefly I went in an audition for
something she was a casting director she
thought it was funny I said we should
come see me do comedy she gave me her
card and I emailed her I'm thinking I
got to have casting directors come see
me if I want to work in this community
in this town so she shows up and uh and
the comedy show was the next night I
messed up I brought her to a comedy show
on March 18th and the show was on March
19th and there's nothing upstate there's
no comedy upstairs it's just nothing so
instead we we just had to get dinner
downstairs at the room at the restaurant
so she and I are eating dinner things
are gonna swell she break out some
edibles you know she had some edibles
there and these are early edibles these
were the ones where you know somebody
came in with a little sack of them from
Pasadena or from Palm Springs or
somebody rolled it you know somebody had
made this [ __ ] you know somebody that
had a oven
or somebody that had cooked him by fire
like these were the kind of edibles
people had cooked over over a hot fire
but these were the old school ones and
she's like if you ever had one I said I
never had one of these one of these you
know these super cookies of dope
so neck sing we've split in this thing
up and I love cookies so she gave me she
said we'll just take a bite and
everybody says that you know and then
the person needs too much it's exactly
what happened to me because I took a
bite and then in my brain I'm just
thinking it's a cookie so I take another
bite well so fast-forward maybe 40
minutes I don't know or even maybe 600
minutes we're sitting there eating
dinner I can't remember how I know this
woman I can't remember if she is my wife
if she is my longtime girlfriend if she
is my fine cousin I can't remember but
next thing man we're standing outside
it's time to go
and I felt laid in my car and I couldn't
even how the valet worked I walked up to
this man and started just just telling
him just describe in my car to him like
it was a game show or something he was
supposed to guess the whole time I got
the little ticket in my pocket anyway so
it's time we're leaving and it's just a
dent it was a business dinner you know
we just and so I go to kiss her I go to
kiss this lady and she's like what what
what's going on now and then I was just
cooked out I was cooked out on that
[ __ ] plant magic man on that mother
nature's frickin vitamin um you know a
mother nature's [ __ ] mother nature's
brain Lawsons that THC I was cooked out
I don't know what was going on
I'm apologizing and everything and you
know I just basically tried to kiss
somebody that had and that had just had
a business dinner with me for no reason
out of the blue but I had no man I
didn't know if this was my I had no idea
I don't if we live together
I had no backstory on us at all
fast forward after that like two days
later she hit me up she's trying to get
me to come over she's bringing me all
this weed you know and we start getting
together and she's you know next thing
you know she's watering plants or
I mean she had these plants set up at
different you know different distances
in her room us you ever seen that show
the grand-prize game it was with Bozo
the Clown where you throw the thing into
the bucket and the bucket keeps getting
further away and if you hit it at a
certain point you get you know free
popeyes chicken for your classroom or
something well I don't know if I don't
know if it was a national show I think
it was on WGN Oh Chicago channel 9 but
this was the it was a game show for
children and it was pretty I mean it was
awesome for kids but maybe it was
perverted maybe it was only in Louisiana
I don't know it might have only been in
Louisiana actually cuz I think one of my
friends was on it one time
but if so they had this thing that's
called Bozo the Clown and he was a clown
that had red hair I guess he was a he
was Irish so he you know is this Irish
man who wore this striped suit and he
looked angry and he had this thing
called the grand-prize game where kids
would they have these buckets and one of
the kids they'd have a group of kids in
the audience one of the kids would get
to come and throw these little ping-pong
balls into the bucket and if he hit the
furthest bucket everybody in the
classroom everybody in his classroom got
chicken free chicken from Popeyes you
know so you'd see all the kids in the
back dude you know especially the young
black because they fired up you know
because then it's not a stereotype
everybody loves chicken but uh but damn
dude this lady could I mean she could uh
she could wall she could wash the ends
of your eyelashes she had act she had
just had accuracy with that vy-jee n--
you know she just had I mean it was like
that movie where that person is the
sniper unless sure what it's called but
yeah I mean she Shh she could die she
could not an eye she could not an eye
from probably about three and a half
feet but that's what it was man and then
we ended up you know getting a sexual
and everything and things happening but
oh the here's the crazy thing
forgot what I was even telling you so
the next day though that edible was in
my system and it was my birthday and I
laid in my bed the entire day afraid to
answer the phone afraid you know my
stepdad called me he sang me happy
birthday every year you know they had
this family that uh
that took me in in high school and every
year this man mr. Rhett that's his name
and he calls me and sings me happy
birthday on my birthday
and that's something you know that's
that's that gives me a sensation man
that's something that gives me a
sensation not an Irish sensation no I'm
not getting Irish but I'm it gave me a
sensation of of being cared about you
know I was in this man's son I mean I
went to live with them do dice to you
they give me a lance I didn't do [ __ ] I
was smoking dope in my room half the
time I remember doing a bunch of donuts
in my score at one time I had a Ford
Escort with no passenger seat so if you
get in the front [ __ ] you get in the
back you know is the only car had two
entrances into the back seat and but I
used to do donuts we had these beautiful
lesbians and live across the street from
us that would do wild Christmas lights
and put like exotic kind of and
everybody said it was like snow
mountains and stuff they built these
basically you know lighted up dicks they
would put these and this [ __ ] looked at
all like I just like they had nine big
dicks in the yard I'm like does that
have anything to do with Christmas are
y'all just trying to catch some sweet
you know y'all just dreaming about dildo
sizes out here but they were beautiful
lesbians and they were beautiful
neighbors and but man I would get I
would do doughnuts in their [ __ ] yard
before school have a fifth of taco vodka
under my seat just living senselessly
you know and this man still would call
me every year on my birthday and I still
spend holidays with them i'ma see them
on Easter in a couple weeks
for a crawfish boil but I spit I still
spend time with that family because they
made me feel cared for and that's what
we got to do for each other out here you
can do that today you could do that
today so if you do something today for
me for my birthday if you want to give
me something just tell somebody you care
about them you know I don't care if it's
a dude I don't care if it's a chick I
don't care if it's a child and you look
at your child or you know make sure it's
your child though you know don't be
don't be smoking cigarettes by that by
that Radio Flyer wagon over there and
Spokane this one's you head on
sunglasses kept going down the slide
like they're about 38 you better check
out but you know huh you know do
something do something do something nice
let somebody know you care do something
nice for somebody you know do something
nice bet you make them feel good cuz um
or if it's somebody you know his
birthday call him leave him a voicemail
the singham Happy Birthday who gives a
[ __ ] you sound like an idiot oh well
because I know what'll make him feel
good man because I know that that's how
it made me feel and here it's been you
know I started living with that family
when I was 14 and here I'm 38 and that's
24 years maybe I don't know yeah and
that man who I didn't fire out of his
Wang that man's calls me every year my
birthday with no sexual interest in me
and just sings me happy birthday so
that's what it's about ma'am if you want
to do something for my birthday as well
I'll say this you can subscribe to the
podcast on iTunes and leave a comment
let's get this beast up the hill over
there you know we're gonna I think I
have a really cool guest coming in maybe
next week might have a guest coming in
this week one of my good buddies coming
in who I love talking to you know may
have some great you know and then it's
just gonna keep coming you know I know
Brendan Schaub is going to come on Bryan
Callen you know we'll get all these
hitters in
here a couple of my favorite authors
have have said that they're willing to
come on so it you know we got some good
things happening so if you can get that
podcast up the hill push this thing up
you know push this thing up so when I
send them the link to go look at this
thing that it shows up on those websites
on those on those charts and that's uh
that's something small you can do for me
man we got some good calls that came in
man a couple that really hit me in the
heart you know a couple that really hit
me in the heart I got a card - somebody
gave it to me in I want to say in
Spokane maybe in Tacoma I'm gonna read
it now just opened it up you can see it
on the YouTube it is a has a hamster on
the front it says don't be shy
time to unleash your inner party animal
happy birthday and it's one of those
cars that used to play music and you
know it's so funny man so small circle
these are the types of thing my mother
would deliver as well - these gas
stations you know she would deliver any
like kind of trinket e-type a thing at
certain times she delivered cookies for
this company called Voort Minh and
that's when I knew I was an addict and I
would go lay in her car at night and I'd
[ __ ] eat 45 sugar cookies dude and
then tell my mother I didn't that's
crazy
who else did it who else did it but the
kid who's sick now and smell you could
smell the sugar and dough in my skin if
I were to sweat a little
you could smell sugar and dough in my
skin well here it is
oh it's got a dancing hamster on it on
this car but i'ma read you this letter
came with it right here said Theo happy
birthday had one of my favorite adults
in the game thank you very much I wanted
to wish you nothing but success in the
future to tell you to enjoy today I'm on
your biggest supporters I just started
my comedy career almost exactly a year
ago you're insane sense of humor has
helped mold me every time I feel nervous
to be myself on stage I will turn on 30
pound bag of hamster bones to remind me
it pays off in the end never doubt
yourself you are funny it says you were
the funniest comedian around because of
that inner voice appreciate you Stephen
Schultz thanks Stephen you know what's
weird man this is gonna sound kind of
crazy when I got to this part where it
said you were the funniest comedian
around I didn't want to read that you
know I didn't want to read that out loud
you know in this and and I'll tell you
why man I don't want to really want to
tell you guys why because there's
something inside of me sometimes that is
afraid to that's afraid to feel good you
know when things start to feel good or
people start having fun sometimes I want
to just I can't do it I got to shut that
down you know there's something inside
of me that um that I think when I was
young I was so used to not feeling good
or you know or just you know I didn't
like myself so much that I got used to
not wanting to feel Joey I didn't want
to feel it because it felt so foreign I
think to me that it it felt like too big
of a leap you know it felt like too big
of a leap to read this never doubt
yourself you're the funniest comedian
around from someone that I don't know it
felt too big of a you know it felt scary
to felt scary to feel good about myself
I don't know if that makes any sense to
anyone or not and maybe it doesn't have
to this you know sometimes these
episodes or this this talking and I
don't know sometimes what I'm what I'm
talking about but I feel what I'm
talking about what sometimes I can't get
the words right
maybe not today you know but maybe in
the future I can but I had some great
calls that came in I want to get onto
this hotline the hotline is nine eight
five six six four nine five zero three
if you are struggling with anything you
know if you experience in the dark arts
you know I've been out there you know I
stay out there you know I got three days
right now no masturbation and I'm
feeling hopeful
you know I fall victim easy to that next
thing it was sugar cookies
it was doing donuts in a lesbians yard
whatever it was that next hit
I always need whatever I needed
something anything that kept me from
feeling myself that's what I needed a
man I'm grateful that I I'm grateful
that I'm here today with you guys I
surely am man somebody I don't know gave
me a nice letter you know and now we're
gonna do that for somebody else with
some of these calls we're gonna take
these are their letters we're taking
them in we're doing this is full circle
that's what we're do we're gonna do good
things here together and I'm grateful
for you guys being here with me today
let's hit a couple of calls right here
man thank you very much hey oh this is
Brian from Cleveland hey Brian down
there in Cleveland and they had a video
after the basketball championship of a
man eating horse poop out on the street
and if you've never seen that go take a
go take a gander on that boy now we used
to eat mushrooms out of cow poop when I
was young but we never went directly to
the poop and skip the drugs so that was
a real artsy move let's hear more I have
a five-year-old daughter and just wanted
to get your opinion she goes to
kindergarten right now and I'm a single
dad and you know every weekend you know
when that UFC fights are on or MMA
fights whatever you know me my buddies
and my family you watching oh that's
cool man I just started watching them
you know and people have told me that if
you get into these Krav Maga and these
MMA type of environments that you you
learn like a brotherhood you know and I
think that's something I'm starting to
be attracted to about it because in the
beginning I was kind of scared to watch
some of it look so much violence look so
much violence out there people [ __ ]
and lips you know out in a damn you know
people losing lips out in a small you
know eight fenced yard out there that
octagon but thank you for calling you
your family enjoys them more and she's
been learning a lot of things from
watching the fights you know and lately
in school you know she's been rear naked
choke kids and you know double leg
takedown them and you know just doing
all these things all these moves that
she learned from just watching that I
didn't teach her you know on these kids
and you know teachers having a problem
you know she took the kid out about two
weeks ago and Kate was asleep and [ __ ]
bruh sorry hey I'm a I said I said that
let's hear more you know she got
suspended for about three days and you
know I want to get her in jiu-jitsu
school or something you know that's
gonna get that energy out but I was
wondering what is your opinion of what I
should do and how I should handle you
know her trying to fight all these kids
you know and being kind of a bully or
you know kind of just being very very
expressive with her moves that she
learns from from OFC so you know if you
could give up your opinion on that I'll
definitely appreciate you thanks Brian
you know I don't have a five-year-old
but I grew up I have two beautiful I
have three beautiful nieces man you know
I've been just so blessed in that area
and I love watch I mean little girls are
the to me I have two nephews and they're
getting real cool but little girls
watching them grow up and stuff is so
much fun him and watching them be brave
and do things that maybe you didn't have
the opportunity or be able to do as a
child that's it's beautiful but yeah man
if she [ __ ] figure foreign dudes then
that's that's why look let her learn
these methods especially with those legs
she's doing leg locks and she's Ric
Flair and little [ __ ] fourth graders
because I'll tell you this in about six
or eight years then boys gonna be coming
at her with erections bra they're gonna
be coming at her with that straight
blood yoga right in the middle they're
gonna be just you know their dicks gonna
be yogurt up and she's gonna have that
ability you know she's gonna be able to
put that you know put somebody's nutsack
in a rear naked choke bra and they'll
never get naked again around dry bet so
some of these skills are going to come
in handy but
I think I think I think you're on the
right track I think it's I think it's
nice it's nice to see an empowered girl
like that feeling confident about
herself but definitely I think you can
you can guide her into knowing when is
right and when it's wrong to use you
know now wrestling moves if she wants to
watch some wrestling [ __ ] there were
some old Jimmy Superfly Snuka if she
wants to jump off a [ __ ] tree branch
you know an elbow drop a couple of
[ __ ] snot-nosed cats that are trying
to get up get up at her then that's okay
that's okay
that kind of wrestling is 100 percent
okay when you get more into that problem
a guy that MMA that UFC now that's us
more technical and that's real so people
could really get hurt but I think you
have a great opportunity to organize
what she's gonna do what she's doing
right now and get her to feel that
passion and energy because then she's
gonna be able to teach other kids and
other young ladies who were interested
some of the same skillset you know and I
think you know maybe some more like
karate type of stuff I mean I always
thought dudes that did karate when I was
young we're ridiculous or some Tai Chi
maybe but that kind of stuff I think it
seems to show you more of like holding
the value in holding your power and
being in and you know and and being that
statue and not just being that straight
up you know that straight up you know
that six-year-old [ __ ] attack you
know you stabbing people with pencils
and [ __ ] you know and just Rainbow Brite
and [ __ ] and choking them out
so you know I think get her organized
because she's with her with her ability
in her desire she's gonna be able to
lead others if she has some organization
and it seems like as a parent you that
that probably wouldn't be too hard for
you to provide but I think it's cool man
I think it's beautiful I think it's
awesome you care so much about what's
going on with your daughter
but yeah don't let her bully run around
out there just beating up kids for no
reason it's scary
they had this they had this girl when I
was growing up named Kizzy her name was
Kizzy and she would beat all the boys
ass and the scariest part about that was
after a while I started
sorry for her because you could tell
that she probably really wanted some
affection from boys but boys were afraid
to give her affection even if she was a
pretty girl she just happened to be
really tough when we were young and she
probably you know she came from some
tough circumstances but but at a certain
point it didn't serve her well to act
that tough all the time because it made
boys afraid to care about her you know
and so she didn't have dates to the
dances and she you know and then she
felt like she had to take on this
persona of always being tough and you
could start to see that that kind of
weird on her but yeah man it seemed like
you're in control of it but thank you
for calling Brian I appreciated those
are some thoughts of mine also I have no
children I don't know but but I'd love
to have some one day I think which is
crazy because I never used to think that
that's crazy man it's crazy how you know
they say a leopard never changes its
spots I don't believe that I don't
believe that let's take another call
here we go hey Bo my name is Kara and
I'm from New York hey Kara from New York
thank you for calling hello anyway I am
a pretty normal person again with a
little bit of an unusual job you have
people calling in for that I am an
animal agent which means that I work
with animals in movies and TV
commercials and TV shows and GreenEDGE
ooh so you working with star animals no
way we have to call you again because I
want to know about some of them I worked
on a set one time with Sabrina the
Teenage Witch they have a cat in there
not the puppet the real cat I worked
with that cat in a commercial one time I
worked with a dog one time that was in
that movie with Will Smith at the end of
the world where he's like the last
person alive I am Legend work with that
dog I saw a woman had a batch of this
lady had every animal you could think of
I went to her home out there and she
lived out I want to say west of Los
Angeles like north of Los Angeles she
had every enemy you could think of down
to lice and ticks
and she'd have a certain number of them
and she represented she took care of him
and they had agents she had head lice
that had agents that were represented in
the industry absolutely baffling thanks
for calling Kara let's hear more on word
we do all kinds of fun animals not just
dogs be happy oh I always wanted a show
animal ever since I saw Green Mile and
that man had those show mice you know
and that reminded me of growing up
around you know I grew up in a stray
animal belt and so we get wild animals I
mean I'm we had a [ __ ] batch of damn
lemurs came through one year and I don't
want to say they were French but they
had the best posture I'd ever seen they
stood on two feet and there was probably
almost maybe five of them and they knew
each other and so I've always you know
had a unique fear and infatuation of
animals you you know from getting
attacked by him and also being intrigued
by him homework we do alligators and
snakes and all right we'll just about
anything dang you sound you sound like
you might want to hire Brian's
five-year-old daughter to get out there
and catch something you know I'd love to
see her put a uh look to see her choke
out a [ __ ] salamander here we go but
the real reason I call is what is up
with handicap bathrooms or what is the
protocol with handicap bathroom so it
might be more of a female a human a
males if you are not quite sure because
you stalls for everything but going into
a typical woman's bathroom
there are regular soles and then there's
usually one sole for handicap and I
always just kind of use it as you know
you're waiting online and if that's the
one open and that's when you go into but
yeah look I think that's it I don't
think yeah if you're in a bathroom and
there's a handicap stall nobody's in it
you don't wait around for a handicapped
person you know if that's what you're
asking like you don't have a
responsibility just to like you know to
help a handicapped person up to the
toilet you know so you can use it if a
handicapped person shows up you have to
get out you know it's almost like a uh
you know they get to go
first it's like at a gangbang really if
you're in a gangbang in a handicapped
person shows up they [ __ ] first you know
you know you don't [ __ ] while somebody's
over in the corner being blind or being
you know only having you know you know
one leg or no arms or something or in a
sling or you know you don't you so it's
just protocol you let them go first
I've spent a ton of time in handicapped
bathrooms I used to be I used to have
this fear sometimes of being in the
airport and fear of flying and when I
went to the airport the first plate
thing I would go to I'd go in the
handicapped bathroom and sit in there
for about 40 minutes not even do any uh
any poops or pees and I would just sit
in there you know and I would sometimes
I would even imagine what it was like to
have certain types of handicaps because
I've always really had an affinity for
the disabled and always you know
marveled at the abilities of people with
disabilities you know that a due to my
town no arms people know I've talked
about him as do Gert Edgerton was his
name but they call him Gert which is
just it's short it's if you take adverts
and you take the beginning in the end
off of it you get Gert and he had no
arms and he would [ __ ] choke people
out all the time
this dude was choking brah you don't
even talking [ __ ] you think he ain't
gonna do nothing and sudden you getting
choked out like he just grew two arms
but he didn't he was snatch you up with
his neck he would just he would get you
between his neck and chin he would take
you down to the mat but I think look use
them handicap this is this is crazy
thing in the world about handicapped
people we can't say handicapped we can't
mention and we can't they want us to be
a part of their lives
you know handicapped people want to be
included in the story you know they want
to be a I don't care I don't care if
somebody don't have arms or legs or a
head if they got a good heart in their
chest let's go that's all I care about
you know people putting all these
handicapped dude I'd love to I'd love it
if they just came to regular restroom
you know I'd hold the dude on the toilet
while he shits if I have to
that's Brotherhood that's you know
that's old school that's Native American
type stuff I mean that's cocaine
behavior really holding on to a buddy
while he [ __ ]
I mean if you haven't done that you
haven't done some good blow I remember
one time and I don't know where this was
I think in could have been over in New
York or Virginia Beach man we got some
shady shady cocaine and this dude had to
[ __ ] one of our buddies and he had a
[ __ ] and he couldn't but he had like his
whole body was [ __ ] but the yeah man
I'm sorry to be talking about this kind
of gross but but he couldn't do it and
so we had to get two or three dudes in
there
to push on his abdomen you know just
literally squeezing his that body as
much as he could until finally he just
blew [ __ ] so you know sometime you got a
if hey if people's handicapped then
that's it
because we all get handicapped sometime
this time you're not handicapped maybe
next time you will be this time you have
a certain body type next time you get
the other time you'll be back you'll be
somewhere next after this life
experience in the other side of the coin
whatever that coin is because a lot of
its perspective you know we don't really
live in different worlds but we
definitely live in different
perspectives but yeah look if you're
handicapped or you got a friend
attending camp you party with them Cara
and you [ __ ] get them an animal you
know get them a sack a head lice or
something I'll bill it to me get them a
couple of gerbils throw a GPA get a
freakin paraplegic you know and I'll pay
for that you know because it's amazing
you know it's amazing the power when you
it's amazing the power the it's amazing
the feeling you get the sensation back
to that that you get that feeling of
just you know I feel impressed when I
see somebody that has a has a disability
and they're able to manage and thrive
and be happy man that makes me it's
impressive
it puts things
in a perspective and we need that but
yeah if you got to borrow their [ __ ]
for a few minutes carry you get in there
baby you do something dirty in there I'm
not gonna say a word you sound like a
good woman we got two more calls here
that I want to get to and I'm super
grateful for you guys for being here
with me on my birthday you know I'm so
I'm so you know I'm 38 and and as hard
as I don't want to admit it sometimes
I'm pretty happy you know as much as
that for some reason I just something
inside of me is just you know it's not
used to admitting it it's that same
thing I think that you know just I had
over the years it's that same thing
flaring back up I just wanna admit
sometimes when I'm feeling good because
I guess I just you know I don't know I
was so used to not feeling it when I was
young that I'm afraid it's not gonna
stick around but we're working together
boy and we got this gang gang gang gang
man they had this guy that came out in
Spokane right he came out and he write
when the show started he's just yeah
he's yelling Gang Gang and he was that
you could tell he was as he loved this
past week and he was into it all man and
nine minutes later dead asleep you could
see he went out and done the st. Patty's
Day and lived his life to the fullest
and he was gonna get to that show no
matter no matter hell or high water or
how many Irish dudes came at him for
BJ's or whatever you know matter how no
matter how Irish it got for him he was
showing up and he showed up man and then
nine minutes later he was I mean he was
he was like at the second or third table
off to the right in Tacoma in the Late
Show and he was dead asleep but I knew
that he was uh I swear he had a smile on
his face I swear he did and I think cuz
the rest of us were having such a good
time he couldn't help but enjoy it he
couldn't help but catch a hit off that
joy through his ears oh let's get to
another call that we had right here oh
we have people that call in if you had a
good weekend or a bad weekend call in
leave it on the hotline and each month
we're gonna give out one of
we got this batch of blue blue
correctional gray blue a correctional
blue of the Correctional Center blue
that's the only way to describe this
color Correctional Center of blue
t-shirts whoever had the best or worse
weekend you got to leave the voicemail
try to leave it in 60 seconds or less
on the hotline and whoever had it we're
gonna we're gonna we're gonna share
their weekend or whatever and and we're
gonna give them a shirt whoever did it
you know whoever had the best one let's
listen to this one right here if we can
learn this one to us only she's family
and podcast understand thanks Aaron I
appreciate that and this has just been a
feel-good episode man a lot of these
calls people saying nice things and I'm
not trying to toot my own horn but you
know I don't you know but um I'm not
doing that from own ego but I appreciate
it homeward thank you ladies man just
have a question you know I got a bad
relationship oh this is a different call
let me hear this call first actually
this is the dude with the weekend sorry
about that
here we go hey Theo this is Nate from
Massachusetts just calling us share the
best weekend I had in a long long time
all right Nate from Mass boy Nate
Nathaniel Nathaniel and I think that's a
name in the Bible maybe you're in some
other I think a different book actually
let's hear more I got to spend a
beautiful sunny late winter Saturday out
on the ice session with my six-year-old
son and both of his granddaddy's OS
sounds like that movie where the two old
guys fight and that movie is called
Graham fathers I think it's like
grandfather summer camp or something
with Jacqueline and who's actually
buried by my house and Walter Matthau
and he and they are both buried by where
I live in Los Angeles and and it's about
senior citizens fighting about stuff and
they they go fishing but let's hear more
you know by the time I was old enough to
remember him half my grandparents have
passed
yeah grandparents used to die a lot
earlier more young you know these kids
nowadays they get it all they get the
iPads and they got the pokemon card you
know they ain't getting as many diseases
armor we used to all get a disease dude
everybody had [ __ ] you know some type
of syndrome or you know their spine was
you know just working freelance
everybody's [ __ ] living a little bit
Jenga in the back all the scoliosis
tests all of that everybody was coming
in you know one of their eyes didn't
work super good they had to hold their
eye open while they took tests and [ __ ]
everybody had something but now
everybody's living joyously and having
all their grandparents let's hear more
and by then the other half maybe didn't
have time to go out and spend a whole
day out in the ice with another
youngster yeah that's the truth remember
that back in the day your grandparents
they couldn't buy the time you knew him
they couldn't do nothing there was
eating gelatin that was it it was just
shoveling gelatin and you know just
stuff in her faces with gelatin and
doing suppositories and stuff when they
could when they could catch a little hit
off of you know a batch of a
prescription you know armor my dad will
put his Walker my dad had a walker he
put it out in the yard that was our
jungle gym we climb around on his Walker
out there in the front yard [ __ ] just
spinning off that [ __ ] and it's landing
out in the mud dude had a beautiful
dismount actually I had a beautiful
dismount when I was probably about six
and a half boy like damn Dominic Mogi
Dominic is it Mookie Yost you you know
I'm talking about Gabby Douglas let's
hear more but it was a real special day
and I hope my son gets to carry it with
them into the future I know that I got
to take a little bit of time and sit
back and appreciate watching him out
there with my father and my
father-in-law just love and last running
around like a little rascal on the ice
watching flags pop catching the bass and
chain pickerel that's what the new
studio brother thanks Nate wow that's a
great call man that's a great call and
you can hit the hotline with your best
or worst weekend whatever your weekend
was like you don't have to and it needs
to be something that just happened so
just make it fresh and there's no
pressure we'll do
every month we're gonna give away one of
those Correctional Center blue t-shirts
to whoever's you know kind of hit home
the most and and we appreciate Nate yeah
it's a beautiful feeling man seeing that
you know seeing what that's like
I remember my grandparents when I was
probably six years old
maybe five or six because I had a long
gap where I didn't get to spend time
with him but they took me fishing for
the first time and I was walking on this
trail up to a concern it was an old
fishing camp out just in rural Illinois
it was called a concern and it was
awesome and they had just spoon river
flowed through there or around there and
they had you know you would he you've
probably read those plays the Spoon
River anthology 's and anyhow a snake
this black snake and I'm not getting
racial the snake was black it has
nothing to do with anything it wrapped
itself around my boot and my grandmother
saw it I didn't see it she said stop
don't move and she had this big stick
right and she swung that thing and hit
me in the [ __ ] shin I mean I can
still feel the pain the paints didn't
even it hurt so bad it didn't even start
in my shin it started in my stomach it
just like oh I just wanted a I mean it
almost just made both my lungs crawl out
of my out of my out of my face and just
look for hope in the distance so she did
that to me but yeah that sounds like a
beautiful time that you had and thank
you for sharing that Nate we got this
other call that came in right here uh
here we go learn this one to a song
she's family and podcast understand
thank you very much Aaron thank you
hilarious man just every question you
know I got out of a bad relationship
with this girl about blab three years
ago okay welcome out and since then I
don't know man that you really can
engage
so when she broke it off and she left me
for some other dude I kind of left me in
a bad rat and I just I think I got like
this then I'm traumatized from it
because I can't exactly I post form in
the same way I used to anymore because I
got that fear and I got that that trauma
so I guess my question for you is I mean
have you been that situation before if
you have how do you deal with it because
I'm open to any ideas thank you for
calling Aaron I've I've been in that
situation before where I felt from
traumatized by approaching Whitmore I
felt scared to approach women yeah yeah
I've been in that situation I think most
of my life I've lived it you know I
think that's a natural fear of a lot of
men so for one don't feel don't feel
alone I think talking to other friends
about it and going with somebody else if
you're really trying to meet a girl in a
bad way you know I met a comedian one
time and this was in Madison Wisconsin
and he told me he said you know what I
do he goes I'll walk up to a woman I'm
interested in and I'll just say look you
really caught my and I'm nervous right
now
but I wanted to say hello and if they're
a decent person a decent woman they're
at least going to communicate with you
they're gonna understand that you're
being real they're gonna feel something
you know long as you ain't creep and
you're not wearing you know long as you
got your shirt sleeves on your on you if
a shirt came with shirt sleeves as long
as that shirt still has those sleeves on
it and you didn't cut them off or you're
not you know and you're you know you're
next cleaning years are clean then a
decent woman is gonna communicate with
you and a nandi a woman that's not worth
it isn't going to now the one who
communicates you might not love you she
might not ask you out you might not
accept your offer if you ask her out but
she's gonna communicate with you and I
think you got a it sounds like you have
to put some of that past two to rest it
sounds like you're still you got this
you know this anchor back there with
this lady how do you let that go well
some of it takes
time you know you can't hurry that some
of it just takes time so what you can do
while that is I mean it just takes time
they say it takes twice as many years to
get over a relationship then you were in
it especially if you were almost engaged
I don't know if that means if you were
afraid to do it or she didn't want to do
it but for whatever reason that didn't
work out it wasn't supposed to work out
wherever you are right now in your life
that's where you're supposed to be you
know there's probably some really good
stuff right around the corner for you
but you gotta be you gotta you got to
show up with your posture each day you
got to look up if you want to see it you
know you're gonna have to wake up and
open your eyes and feel hopeful I
noticed the second I start to feel real
hope like I start to feel hopeful like I
start to go into my day and be like
instead of being like [ __ ] another day
another day where I'm you know not with
her another day where I'm at the same
job or in another day where I have to
sit in traffic her as soon as I think
that way that's why I'm stuck all day so
when I wake up and say guess what
another big dick just woke up in the
universe today guess what I got my eyes
open and I got a strong snout I might
smell a pot of gold in the distance I
might find treasure today you know I
might catch a rare animal I might ride a
unicorn I might kiss a donkey I might do
something anything could happen when I
show up and say yeah I might sit in
traffic today but I might meet a hottie
in my car cuz you know where a girl
can't get away from you in traffic at
least probably not for two to four
minutes so when you bump when you
neck-and-neck with her throw that flirt
roll down your window you know 1%
pulling some 2 Chainz so show somebody
who show her your vibe without saying a
word sometimes you can show your vibe
without even saying a word boy you know
ride around with one of those those oh
there's party things you get at a party
the things that bother everybody that
they they roll out and then roll back in
one of those little party favors throw
those in the car put on some [ __ ]
Nelly you telling me if at you now you
tell me if you drive pass a good girl
and you busting some Nelly and blowing
those party favors and if she don't look
over twice that's not on you that's on
her
you just gratefully lost a bad girl be
grateful when you lose the bad ones
that's another thing you know you see a
girl you're nice to her you said
something nice it's ok chic as long as
she's if she's nice and friendly and
cordial good there's a good girl but
some girl this is say they want to be a
connor they want to be rude because you
just said hello or you're trying they
know you're nervous and they still just
shut your nerves down you'd be grateful
you didn't end up with that broad
because you won't have fun [ __ ] her
for a couple weeks and then you are
gonna lose half your money tour in nine
months
somehow through some dirty alimony or
something you know whatever the play
whatever path you're on right now it's
okay man and you got to take some time
to heal but while you're healing do not
feel bad for taking that time and that
could be the little prison you get
caught in because sometimes you know not
only will I be feeling but not only will
I have some feeling of sadness from
something that occurred prior in my life
but then I'll feel bad for feeling bad
and that uh that's not a good sensation
so if you feel that sensation man you
feel that vibe let that thing go find
something good spend time with some
buddies you know you'd be amazed how you
find find a buddy that has a good
girlfriend and guess what guess who
guess who she'll know other good
girlfriends you know sometimes we think
it's this element where we got have just
put all of it to meet somebody get
involved in a different and a program
something new something different man
you'll find somebody you'll find
somebody and you'll find them when
you're ready you know you but you show
up hopeful to each day man
you show up hopeful brah cuz if I'm
gonna sit here and be hopeful for you
then you better be hopeful for yourself
I'm saying don't put it all on me man
this
the call came in man we're gonna finish
up right here man and this was uh I want
to play it for you guys first but Aaron
good luck man keep your head up dude I
love you bro
you know and if I was you know if I was
a little more Irish I'd get Irish with
you I try to help you out there but if
anything you can always just wait till
next st. Patty's Day and at least get a
load off you know from somebody from
anybody here we go let's hear more all
right say aye mate um I'm not sure if
it's obvious from my tone but a little
bit uncomfortable leaving this message
but okay no worries brother you know
that's okay man I've been uncomfortable
I've been uncomfortable man so don't
feel uncomfortable please just saw what
someone to talk to about this and I know
the CIO's one past weekend family think
that some people who can give me some
useful feedback yeah man we can we can
certainly we can try it if we can onward
um I guess I've run into a bit of a
crossroads in my life so a charting ship
yeah I've got a bit of a different drug
problem and yeah I don't know my
problems got um keep on justifying
everything with right self PE and I
don't know at what point you stop
feeling sorry for yourself that's like
my question but yeah I'm kind of trying
absolute [ __ ] drivel the yeah man new
you know man
onward I love the show been listening
for like a year now you know and take it
easy
thanks for calling man I appreciate it
you know you weren't talking to absolute
drivel you know I appreciate Colin
excuse you man uh yeah I appreciate you
calling do it okay you know at what
point I'm gonna hear this one more time
and it's when he this one more time
yeah I don't know my problems got um I
keep on justifying everything with right
self-pity and I don't know at what point
do you stop feeling sorry for yourself
that's like my question but yeah I'm
kind of trying absolutely at what point
do you start feeling sorry for yourself
you know it's crazy man it can become an
addiction a fear ended up feeling sorry
for yourself can almost become an
addiction in itself because when you
feel sorry for yourself Italy it's a
feel it's it's it's at least a feeling
you know and sometimes after a while
it's like the only thing you know how to
feel and it's sad man it's an
unfortunate situation but guess what
you're not alone man you're gonna be
okay
I thought about this earlier actually I
listened to this call and it really hit
home for me and so I actually wrote down
my answers because I want to be able to
you know express myself as clearly as I
can first I want to say thank you and
also I wanted to read this actually
because the same call or send an email
as well that explained he sent a text
message into the hotline that explained
his thoughts a little more he said Theo
Vee the boy this is me again hitting
hitting you up from London UK if my
memory serves me correctly my voice
messages I left were pretty
incomprehensible
I'm bombarding you with messages and
calls at this point but it's want to
clear things up I can write better than
I can talk I live the first 19 years of
my life an excessive comfort the perfect
family and no worries about anything in
the last year everything has collapsed
my dad was diagnosed with MS and my mom
has suffered a schizophrenic episode and
left my dad I know still my life is
cushy but the adjustment from never
having faced anything
cult to a storm of shite raining down on
my face has been difficult consequently
I've justified letting my life
completely separate to my family fall
apart and I've been taking coke a
cocaine more days and I haven't for
months now and I think it's time to stop
it seems stupid but I've listened to
your podcast every [ __ ] fki in that's
that British version and I like that
every [ __ ] episode for about a year
now and although you don't know me I
feel like I know you can you offer any
advice because I want to take my life
back into my hands love you bro yeah man
I just appreciate you sharing you know I
appreciate you you know being brave
enough to say some of these things man
because uh you know I can I can
sympathize
you know I've Javy I was man you got me
hooked up here I've been right there man
you know I've been right there so just
know that the place when you feel when
you that those feelings that you you're
not alone and and I appreciate you
calling and sharing about them and I
wrote down some suggestions you know I
wrote down some suggestions man cuz I
care bro I care about you you know I
never been a huge fan of the British but
I love you bro well I want you to say I
wanted I wanted to know that you know
you made a big step I realize and you
have a problem that you can't handle and
you've taken a good step by reaching out
to anyone to anyone man you know that's
the first step because now this thing
isn't just yours anymore you know you're
taking a step and I'm grateful for that
and a lot of people don't take those
steps for many years you're 19 you're 20
you doing the stuff now and you're gonna
have you have a bright future
you've already like you're already aware
kind of a crossroads it sounds like you
know a lot of drug abusers and
alcoholics you you know you reach a
point where where where you don't know
what to do you don't know what to do
your life becomes unmanageable because
you're managing it but it's not you're
not doing it well
and then it comes to the point where
almost it's managing you but but
self-pity you had asked about it's a
feeling that grows on itself it's almost
like you know itself if you stay like
inside and feel depressed and you don't
go out in the Sun the depression will
build it's almost like moss on a tree it
builds on the side away from the Sun so
self-pity is a feeling that grows on
itself there's no way out of it by
feeling more of it if that makes any
sense to you there's no way out of
self-pity by feeling more self-pity but
there are people and programs that can
help change your perception about what
you're going through
slowly but surely what you're going
through it doesn't sound fun but numbing
it with drugs only makes the reality of
it worse to wake up to every day you're
establishing a cycle that will just get
harder to get out of the longer that you
don't face it you don't have to worry
about helping your family right now
you know you can because you're not
gonna be able to help them if you can't
help yourself so you got to get into a
better place it sounds like it's too
much it sounds like too much pressure if
you think I have to help my family I
have to get you know sober up right now
and help my family that's too much
pressure all you have to do right now is
just care about yourself and I feel like
that's what you're doing and I can't
tell you if you have a problem I can't
tell you you know everybody's life is
different but I can tell you that there
are people and programs out there that
can help you live in a much more
comfortable place and you I know it's in
the South crazy you're gonna think it's
not possible that there's not and I'm it
is it is a hundred percent possible you
know I mean I've been there you know I
don't know if I've been in the same
place as you but I've been in a place
where I was just doing I was doing drugs
cuz he I just it was the only feeling I
could I needed drugs to have a feeling
it just made me feel [ __ ] up and that
was the last feeling I could I was just
having so much trouble feeling anything
else and so I was like oh here this so
at least it makes me feel [ __ ] up but
not anymore man you know not right now
right now I'm having a day where I am I
am getting feelings from other people
I'm able to sit here and feel what
you're feeling and I can really feel it
man I'm not just sitting here saying I
hate it I can feel it I can feel what
you're feeling and I wouldn't be able to
do that if I didn't get some help for
myself
so Allah I'll text you as well man I
know your number came through the
hotline and I'll text you and hit you up
and maybe we can jump on the phone too
if there's anything else I can talk
about privately but I'll put I
appreciate you hitting the hotline man
that's huge you know you just made my
birthday you know I hope in some moment
today in my life or this week in my life
that I'm able to be as strong as you
were by being you know probably as uh
probably as honest you know just as
being as honest and being as brave to
[ __ ] say hey you know something's
going on with me and it doesn't feel
okay so you know I appreciate that man
thank you very much
and I got a I got a run on the Comedy
Store guys I gotta be there actually in
about 20 minutes and I'm not trying to
bail on you I'm not trying to bail on
anybody but it's heading into my
birthday if you have any thoughts or
suggestions or any feelings or anything
that came into you ideas suggestions for
any of these callers it hit the hotline
please feel free feel free to hit the
hotline nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three and share those
thoughts and share those feelings and we
will see if maybe will put them in on
the next episode and we can get back and
that way some of our listeners can get
back to some of the people that called
in and if not if you have a different
issue or thought or suggestion or
anything you want to talk about you got
a question for me
hit me up let me know making me about
anything but you know what find a way to
feel something find a way to feel
something because that's why I'm here
you know that's why I'm here you know I
don't want to feel bad anymore you know
I don't want I want to feel some
sensations and I want to feel good
so if you got to get Irish you know if
you got to propose to somebody if you
got a you know tell your your cousin
that you hate if you got to just hug him
you know whatever you got to do find
somebody find somebody and [ __ ] feel
something you know and feel something
and I love you over there in London man
keep your head up dude you got this you
know you started out used to write the
right this moment you started something
you started making your life better you
started making your life better I
promise you that and also you know
anything I say on these shows these are
suggestions I don't I don't know
anything I just know you know just some
of my own things what I've been through
but I love you guys man you'll be good
to yourselves hit the hotline for my
birthday gift subscribing on iTunes
throw a comment up there could just be
anything you know it could be anything
and ni and I appreciate you guys so much
we might have an episode on Thursday
we'll see we're getting the studio put
in I'm so close to be able
have a guest thank you patreon Thank You
great block Thank You star flow we'll
have links to all of those at the bottom
of the podcast I will be in Tampa
Florida on April 6th and 7th I will be
at bananas comedy club on April 20th and
21st and in Hackensack New Jersey and I
will be in Calgary
June 15th through the 17th in Calgary
Canada at Yuk Yuk's comedy more sets
coming soon more dates you can support
on patreon you can hit up the you can
grab a non-word t-shirt at theof on Comm
slash store tickets at theof on comm
slash tour and be good to yourselves man
because I know you deserve it happy
birthday to you guys man thank you so
much for being here with me man I feel I
feel okay
[Music]
celebrate live
cellophane is
[Music]
died